hello readers you know it's better than
reading a book reading two books reading
a bunch of books reading a mountain of
books
this may sound self-evident but great
readers read a lot of books good readers
read widely they read lots of different
types of books sometimes these books
will be similar and sometimes they'll be
very different but one thing that good
readers do is think about how what they
are reading might connect with other
books they've read in the past they
think about how books connect with other
books I have been reading a lot this
year mostly cookbooks mysteries and
science fiction novels so they're alike
in some ways and different and others
right now I'm reading these mystery
novels that take place in Australia
they're all written by the same person
and they all feature the same main
characters a collection of books that
are about the same character in
different situations is called a series
reading a series is a great way to see
how the same characters grow and change
over a longer period of time there's the
hero of the series with a fabulous
feather in her hair and a magnifying
glass ready to solve some mysteries now
not all books by the same author are
automatically part of the same series
authors can write standalone books or
start completely different series here's
the author hard at work on a typewriter
an ancient writing device if you don't
know what that is politely ask an older
person often writers have a similar
writing style even when what they're
writing is not connected for example if
you like funny books and you find an
author that makes you laugh chances are
that the other books they write could
also be funny books can have similar
plots so the series I've been reading is
a mystery the main character is a
detective and she figures out how and
why someone committed a crime after many
years of reading I've learned that I
really like books that share this
quality of a hero that solves mysteries
but just because two books are both
mysteries doesn't mean they're going to
work the same way two mysteries by two
different writers with different
characters and situations are going to
be pretty different from each other as a
reader I have to be
careful not to assume that I know where
a book is going to go just because I'm
familiar with what kind of story it's
telling it's like fairy tales right
every culture around the world has
traditional stories and the stories all
pretty much have the same purpose which
is to teach people how to behave like a
good person there are stories all around
the world that have a similar structure
to the story of Cinderella young poor
girl with an evil stepmother unfairly
punished and then through magic and the
goodness of her own heart she marries
into royalty there are thousands of
versions of this story from every
culture on earth I love reading stories
from all over the world because it helps
me understand the values that different
cultures share or how they differ this
is why it's fun to read lots of stories
from different times and different
people it can help us understand what's
important to people what was important
to people in the past or what's
important to us now and it's fun reading
lots of books is fun you might find an
author or a character that you love you
might be transported to a whole new land
or time reading widely and thinking
about how books connect is the best way
to become a better reader and you might
just solve a mystery or two while you're
at it you can learn anything Dave it out